und wussten nicht recht voran so schwer
dieser folgt jetzt hierhin ungefähr da
war wenn du nicht und wo es leon leben
kommt nicht mit der hat noch keine
sachen der wird sein haus zweiter baum
ich her macht bestimmt irgendwelche
sachen wenn wir nicht da wo er wir haben
übrigens ch redet mal über julias block
und was ihr davon haltet davon was
haltet ihr davon einmal blockiert weil
der fall die von der geile sehe also ein
wort lappen weil das wort hat er geprägt
ist mainstream geworden lappen
früher hat könnte man seiner bisschen
sehr mit mit schwarzem humor und als
begründen aber weil es einfach nur dabei
ist einfach nur schwachsinn über über
investoren
ich wollte hier mehr schauen ob das
wasser halb blau ist ich wollte gerne
also ich finde allgemein trainingsblock
ich hab ja schon mal im video gesagt
weil ich wirklich ziemlich anderen
fragen bekommen habe war selbst von
elfter september wir müssen dagegen
vorgehen ich meine er kann machen was er
will und er merkt er selber das ist bei
der community man schlecht ankommt weil
damals war es echt noch sarkasmus und
ich fand allgemein die serie julie julia
bild fand ich sehr gern schmucks aus
aber mittlerweile finde ich einfach nur
noch hin geschlossen sachen wie zum
beispiel hier ich zähle jetzt beim
menschen auf dich töten will weil die
nerven weil sie im kino da ich einen
zentimeter weniger als ehre und das ist
voll schwarzem humor und dann sind da
die ganzen also ich sehe das ja auch an
auf meiner schule wenn ihr dazu hört was
siebtklässler erzählen was von dem
elfter september video
heute fragt dann erfolgt eine 3000 opfer
ich verdoppelt den einsatz die feuerwehr
voll witzig keine keinen sinn da werden
die fitness einfach der tabubruch den
geil finden
aber wenn der tabubruch irgendwie sinn
hätte aber er hat gar keinen sinn
denn er hat einfach seinen sinn mein
problem ist dass es keinen sinn hat
wasser macht und naja jetzt aber jetzt
auch nicht wirklich sind die sollen
unterhalten er will auch nur unterhalten
darauf eine andere art ja sagt zwar
immer bei also stets auch erklärt hat
schwarzer humor hat keine grenzen
deswegen kann man sich die grenzen daher
selber setzen deswegen ist der schwarze
humor
allerdings finde ich schon dass er bei
seinem schwarzen wort deutlich
übertreibt schreiben sondern das ganze
keinen hintergedanken hat schwarze moor
hat er auch auf schwarze humor hat
irgendwo ein sinn dahinter zum beispiel
ziemlich schwarzen humors park zum
beispiel oder aber das hat immer
irgendwo einen sinn
gesellschaftskritik zum beispiel
trainingsblock hat gar keinen sinn zum
beim elfter september wieder aber null
immer was halt dieses mal will das nicht
so ja klar der benutzer hat seine
fanbase dazu aus der taufe die zuschauer
und ich will einfach nur provozieren und
damit die leute auf sich lenken
das ist ihm scheißegal wer den nachweis
schuldig dass er so heuchlerisch immer
was macht ein skelett hier dass er so
heuchlerisch immer hier kein partner ich
will auch kein geld verdient mit der
ganzen sache das hat einfach früher
immer gesagt und erst erfolgt erst voll
partner hat natürlich benutzt natürlich
keine partner features wie samt mails
oder banner an oder sonst nutzt alles
nicht damit auch die kleinsten kleinen
kinder denken macht das ja gar nicht
fürs geld erst mal cool und dann hat er
bei jedem video aber volle werbung
geschaltet
noch vor den jeans blog battle videos wo
er gar keine arbeit hatte also die von
den zuschauern gemeldet sind und die
also von kiko oder was ihr von herzen
von den teilnehmern gemacht wurden
die musik wie das da der 0 arbeit dran
alle monetarisiert die haben eine
million klicks gut oder mal eben zwei
3000 euro mit verdient und neun macht da
nicht mit geld oder ihre sendung bei
itunes verkaufen
ja ich verkaufe das jetzt nur bei itunes
weil ihr dass er unbedingt wollte und
ihr wollt nicht unterstützt deswegen
mache ich das jetzt nicht weil ich das
will erlaubnis
typisch der jackpot horst r was ich
damals echt geil fand waren rap analysen
das war echt geil ersten rap analysen
allgemein zu seinem ersten videos aber
mit der zeit einfach immer behindert hat
genauso lj chen jin gegen irgendwas
schön versus oder www das hieß eltern im
netz das fand ich auch noch ganz
interessant dass das auch noch ganz cool
dass mich ausgang aber befremdlich hatte
damals lebten damals über minecraft
kennengelernt die in den abo box
empfehlungen des beweises ich vor einem
jahr oder so
damals bei 30.000 patienten abonniert
als er was zu kollege gemacht hat 40
minuten analyse fand ich extrem geil
bearbeitet das sein bestimmt mehrere
monate dran oder mehrere wochen
naja unterhalt mit seiner bearbeitet hin
was ist bei arbeiten mit seiner stimme
der schreibt seine texte vor und auch
mit betonung mit alles drauf geachtet
und so und das ist halt ne die stimme
das vermittelt den eindruck als ob da
jemand echt ahnung hätte und ob man dem
hundertprozentig da naja ob als ob alles
was er sagt recht stimmt richtig ist und
das nutzt er halt geschickt aus meine
meinung
bei meiner meinung abgegeben spoiler als
nachhaltig für den crafter muss meine
meinung ehrmann begründung gab seine
person die hat ein video gemacht ja
crafter du bist voll scheiße weil du
kriegst studenten flugzeug voll viele
abonnenten und die anderen nicht und
deswegen bis zu cacau weil du abonnenten
kriegs um die anderen nicht du arsch und
ich so alter das war sein einziges
argument dass ich scheiße bin weil ich
mehr abonnenten bekommen als
irgendwelche anderen lena was mir bringt
letztes auch aufgefallen ist dass ich
dich mal geputscht hat ja bei dann
vergessen bei
das sind mit zusammen mit zwei anderen
gepusht mit mit maxl irgendwie ja ja
aber ich mache die überhaupt noch sachen
ja ich glaub nicht also ich weiß habe
ich an einem tag dass er richtig krass
für mich an einen tag 100 abonnenten
dazu bekommen sonst immer nur so 10
das war dadurch weiß ich ob es für 1000
abonnenten oder sowas neben den trainer
hatte irgendwann im winter und ich
wusste gar nicht wie ich es mir nicht
angeschrieben oder so ich wusste nicht
woher die kam und ich hab meine
zuschauer gefragt sag mal die als neuen
zuschauer bekommt ihn so her komm
kräftig geputzt und dann erstmal socom
kräftige google nein dabei handle
sondern wie man gesund und einem sack in
dem neben video also dabei eigentlich
nur ein video wo ich ein paar infos
gesagt hat und dann habe ich nebenbei
einfach gesagt euro kanal wollten wir
zugesendet pushen okay gut hier
doch richtig kocht von der untergasse da
habe ich ja danke danke geschrieben also
weiter
und das war nicht der erste kontakt dem
wir miteinander hatten oder nach
eigentlich gar nicht mehr in die aber ja
wir hatten uns dann in skype glaube ich
auch aber nie irgendwas zusammen gemacht
so wirklich und irgendwann kam die erste
adventure mit seinem mini gemacht
zusammen
oder ich glaube das war etwas das erste
was wir zusammen gemacht haben
auf ein ticket wirklich so toll
konzentrieren wir haben uns einmal
kennengelernt
ich glaube das war irgendwie dort so
alles gelernt ich kannte sich davor
nehmen da hab ich dich angeschrieben
aber habe ich dann in skype geld oder
wie haben wir das alles gemacht also ich
hab dich bei youtube angeschrieben ja
das weiß ich auch aber wir haben uns bei
skype geändert und allgemein so alles
wie kam es dazu
meine plötzlich angeschrieben wegen dem
projekt wird du nicht oder
war dass wegen dieser let's play woche
weil du da irgendwie mit pete oder
irgendwie sowas da keiner hat man es
glaube ich schon weil weiter kannte mich
hat dann auch schon wichtig wegen dir
nicht wegen den weg und bringt dem dich
mit irgendwas gefragt irgendwann so weit
um den dreh aber ungefähr da in der zeit
haben und weil das wurde häufiger
gefragt
genau wie noch so nicht von crafter
kindern und vor allem war als ich das
erste mal was mit ihr gemacht hast du
glaub ich so 5000 abonnenten oder so und
da frage ich mich eigentlich wie wir
nicht da eigentlich auch nicht so
gekommen also ich hatte den putsch von
damit eigentlich schon wieder vergessen
dass in den letzten jahren wieder
aufgefallen ich weiß auch kann ich bin
auch irgendwann mal bei den neu
gestaltet aber erfreulich es war
berggipfel also der mal den kanal teile
also mit mir gemacht hatte dabei hat
sich das daran erinnern
wir haben wir haben zusammen mit spark
was gemacht kann das sein er war hat es
aber erst später
weil es mich aber angeschrieben davor
glaub ich auch einfach erst mal dass du
mich nur angeschrieben
ja genau so minecraft war geht
kraftpaket und coolen 1
das hat der krieg hat gerade was
geschossen es war das merkwürdig aus ich
muss mir lang immer mein rufen
aufstellen und mir eisenbahn so lange
noch aufnehmen leon wie lange schon
aufgenommen haben was soll eine stunde
und 30 minuten also wir haben gleich
wieder das ist ja schon lange lange zeit
es kam mir bisher nicht so lang vor weil
ich eigentlich ganz etwas zu tun hatte
und so hat sind jetzt wieder vom thema
julians blog auf unsere anfangs
geschichte
weil ich tue ins blog über minecraft
spiel gefunden hat erzählt abgerutschte
dann sind wir genauso wie von essen zu
wasser geschwitzt von von essen von
pizza zudem dünner
dehner dünner da nicht irgendwie meiner
pause und ich soll ja letztens klausur
und dann sah sie auch und dann holen wir
alle unsere lektüren raus und ergreifend
jemand musste josef k verlandet haben
denn ohne dass er etwas böses getan
hätte wurde er eines morgens verhaftet
beste satz beste echte leben
so können wir gar nicht zuende tricksen
sprechen kommen jetzt den letzten vier
minuten fand ich finde ich allgemein
team die 80 was er macht weil es ist
keine arbeit dahinter und die ganzen
kleinen kiddies mögen es wenn er von
seinen sechs geschichten erzählt sie
teilweise nicht mehr stimmt weil alle
seine stories findet man im internet von
vor fünf jahren oder so wirklich fast
alle
er hat ja ja er hat ja mal auf sein das
hat mir auch voll gewundert als er
längst ich mach mal selber aus ich war
auf einer party und blabla und ich so jo
die gleiche geschichte ein komplettes
erzählt problem ist halt dass immer die
ganzen weiß nicht auf youtube sind halt
dieses hat der größte anteil an leuten
ist 12 bis 16 jahre soll keine panik
seien viele doch ist eine beleidigung
alte beleidigung ich war nie so alt und
jung war prima und da finden halt in
dieser altersgruppe gibt es halt vieles
was cool finden so etwas feiern und
decken hellmann was für ein krasser typ
so cool wir ja mal sein und die
identifizieren sie auch mit dem weil ich
bin auch so theo die zocker aber ich
mache auch so partie und nur jetzt bin
ich unterwegs war und ein nicht voll
cool erzählte ich glaube er ist mein
büro mein büro meint bruno scheiße ist
dunkel es kann ja im multiplayer sind
die kripo voll verbuggt also monster
allgemein erst sehen sie eigentlich und
plötzlich bekommt sie angelaufen
find ich ja absolut nicht schön
ich bin eher auf diamanten im moment aus
ich muss hier noch mal hoch bevor ich
meine sachen vergessen sie mir schon
allen kommentaren ist eine sache nicht
aber ich bin schon auf dem weg zurück
plötzlich findet es nur eisen ist zwar
ganz schön aber ich möchte nochmal
diamanten oder so auf welcher in 23
städten keeper kommt von überall ich
meinen blog ab ganz viel travel fällt
runter das war mir auch also ein
kribbeln bringt ein bisschen redstone
netz ich habe ich mich nicht so gut
wirklich element rändern hin
ich traue mich nicht anzugreifen ich
wollte schon ländern sagen hat einer von
euch mal gespielt beide sogar ziemlich
viel jedem apps wie immer im ausland
eigentlich gespielt aber nicht
aufgenommen weil mittlerweile finde ich
das spiel mehr so schlimm als ich hab's
mit musik und zwei kumpels gespielt und
dabei hat mir in vanilla aufgegriffen
das spiel war da total pussy mäßig
warmes umgedreht und man auf freien
flächen
wenn man sich darum dreht und schon paar
seiten hatte diese musik ist schon
eingesetzt wenn man sich darum dreht
steht immer hinter allen ich sagte komm
ich drehe mich als umtriebig untersteht
auch immer weiter dass man muss sich da
richtig wenn man sich glaube ich darauf
einlassen
damit sich auch noch der einzige let's
play die ich mittlerweile abonniert
haben sind minecraft pocket und den
speed habe ich abonniert aber nur weil
ich mein kreft von den gucke und
deswegen ist mein komplettes top box war
sonst hab ich nur noch den abonniert
weil ich finds länder für geil wie viel
leute habt ihr abonniert insgesamt
bestimmt 130 die meisten englisch ich
hab 185 abonniert
120 so schätze ich mal ich hab so
gemacht jeder kanal jeder kanal nicht
cool fände abonniere ich ja also ich wo
ich hoffe dass da was kommt was mich
interessiert
also früher habe ich immer noch jedes
videos der boxee guckt aber es schafft
man auch nicht mehr
und dann zeigt ein youtube manchmal was
nicht an ich verziehe ist ein haus mit
kakteen überall meint aber manchmal wenn
ich zum beispiel bei white city oder
sowas dann habe ich zwar abonniert auch
einfach so die großen deutschland
abonniert um zu wissen was so in der
deutschen szene so abgeht immer mehr was
die so machen
dann gucke ich jetzt auch nicht
unbedingt das video dann zum beispiel
johannesburg auch abonniert obwohl ich
eigentlich scheiße finde ja ich guck mal
hier das video an ich auch nur mich
wieder zu ärgern
ich gucke mir wirklich an der ich auch
was soll ich dachte nie von dir
ich gucke mir wirklich an nur um den wir
zu denken was soll der scheiß
ja ich möchte auch einfach auf dem
aktuellen stand sein was hat er denn
jetzt wieder neues rausgehauen und so
weiter und ich hoffe auch dass da
irgendwann so was kommt wie sollen
solche guten alten serienheld